moindre mesure ici.- Malgré tous
du gouvernement américain, dont
le recours aux produits importés
de l'étranger, une pénurie
aux États-Unis.
C'est la fermeture en février
C'est la fermeturer
dernier, pour des raisons de
salubrité, d'une usine du plusn
de lait maternisé qui a aggravét
chez nos voisins.
Avant la pandémiela demande dé%
l'offre en lait maternisé.
Ce chiffre a doublé durant
la pandémie et presque quintuplé
Partout les stocks sont
est particulièrement pénible
pour les familles à faible
revenu, qui bénéficient
normalement d'un là très bas pr.
La solution du gouvernement
Biden : des incitatifs pour une
augmentation de la productiont
aérien pour approvisionner
les États-Unis. Les deux
premiers vols ont ramené
de bouteilles de lait.
Un troisième vol arrivera
bientôt d'Australie.
Et d'autres suivront.
À l'opposé, le Canada
maternisé. Et sauf exception,
les apprents
sont stables.
MICHEL ROCHETTE, Conseil du coml
- Il arrive que les gens
achètent davantage de produits
que nécessaire, ce qui provoque
une journée souvent, mais,
dans ce s ont
la capacité de renouveler
les étagères à chaque jour.
la situation est beaucoup
quiétante quiétante quiétante qc
et au Canada qu'elle ne l'est
aux États-Unis.préparations de l